the full trailer for season two of the
witcher has finally dropped and fans are
buzzing about the return of this beloved
series from intriguing monsters to
geralt's continued adventures here's
just a few of the small details you
might have missed in the trailer for the
witcher season 2. one of the first fight
scenes shown in the trailer for the
witcher season 2 is between girls and a
woman who's depicted emitting a
superhuman scream as it turns out that
woman is a type of vampire known as a
bruxer who are known for using their
piercing screams to send their enemies
flying since neverland also appears in
the trailer it makes sense to assume
that this brucer is varina who was
introduced in the short story a grain of
truth from the book the last wish in the
story varina and nevalin are lovers and
geralt originally thinks farina is a
nymph called a rusalka though he
realizes that she's much more dangerous
farina could also assume the form of a
giant bat which renders her even more
powerful in her fight against geralt in
the opening of the witcher season 2
trailer we hear a mysterious voice
speaking about how strange the world is
lately and there may be the various
signs for an omen signaling the end of
days gary world doesn't seem to be
concerned though it's then revealed that
geralt is speaking to neverland a ball
like man beast played by game of thrones
actor christopher hivue at about the 118
mark in the trailer we see a mage appear
with a scarred face brandishing a
powerful fire spell he shows up again in
the later half of the trailer this time
attacking an unknown foe the wizard is
rhians played by chris fulton and he is
one nasty customer in the novels riens
is a deadly assassin who is tasked with
capturing siri he is known for being
merciless and willing to do whatever it
takes to find his prey even torturing
people for information in season one we
were only given a quick glimpse of the
elves living in the world of the witcher
in the episode four marks geralt and
yaskir come across two elves angry
refugees who kidnap the pair when they
wander onto their territory the episode
reveals that the once proud race of
elves were driven from their homes and
forced into hiding thanks to humans who
committed near genocide on their people
not all of the elves have disappeared
however in the witcher season 2 trailer
we see a new character introduced a
beautiful female elf her name is
francesca finderbear and she is queen of
the elves as well as a powerful mage in
the books she joins the side of
nilfgaard in the return for the elven
city of del blasfana which she will rule
she also later joins a powerful lodge of
sorcerouses a secret group that hopes to
put sorceresses and power over all of
the continent one of the biggest
storylines in season 2 will tackle
siri's training at cair mohen the home
of the witchers although she has had a
harrowing ordeal so far geralt knows her
trials are just beginning about two
minutes into the witcher season 2
trailer we see geralt and siri facing
off against a wicked looking tree
monster fans of both the books and the
games may recognize this creature as a
leshy or leshen a forest demon who
wreaks havoc upon any who dare cross its
threshold the world of the witcher
boasts many powerful sorceresses yet
some of the most influential characters
are not skilled with magic but wisdom in
the witcher season 2 fans are introduced
to nanika in the books nanake is a
priestess of militele who has counseled
geralt many times over the years as well
as healed his battle wounds in the
trailer we see her offer some words of
wisdom to geralt about siri what you say
about that girl's power is true
you can't help her we can't say much
more without revealing big spoilers but
there's no question that nanaki knows
what dangers are in store for siri in
season 2 it looks like we'll be spending
quite a bit of time in cair moorhen the
legendary keep where witches were raised
and trained to become masterful hunters
while an assault on care morehen
resulted in most of the witches leaving
the keep we know that vesamir still
lives there and siri eventually joins
him and is trained by fellow witches
while we get several glimpses of the
grounds and outside of cair mohan in
this new trailer for season 2 we also
get a close-up of an iconic tree inside
of care morehen's great hall the tree
known as the medallion tree is adorned
with dozens of little hooks the whole
different witcher medallions which once
belonged to witchers who have since died
at the end of the witcher season 1
jennifer is attacked by fringilla vigo a
sorceress from nilfgaard and a member of
the lodge of sorceresses in the season 2
trailer we see jennifer being led in
chains by fringilla alongside other
apparent nilfgaardian prisoners in
another scene from the trailer we see
jennifer almost taunting fringilla when
she says
you're precious leaders after something
you're a pawn to get to it
like many others in the witcher series
the lodge of sorceresses has a history
of wanting to use siri for their
political gain since she's the only heir
of sintra and was born with powerful
magic it looks like siri and geralt will
have their work cut out for them if
they're going to survive season 2 of the
witcher you'll get the chance to see it
for yourself when the show arrives on
netflix december 17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the witcher are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]